[Music]
keep seeing these ads for that zombie
show on tv it's awful
i can't believe people want to watch
that kind of stuff at night no there's
enough going on in the real world to
give me the creeps great thank
you
to the blake family thanksgiving to the
very special chinatown edition of the
black family thanksgiving here here
dad won't get any reception up here we
have to lean up against the window
[Music]
yeah but now
lean in
smush your body up there you go
so are you balancing a job with all your
studies the main reason i'm not done
with school yet is because i was
depressed for a bit
i'm fine now in our family we don't have
that kind of depression done
whoa
come back to earth sorry no we just have
a lot of stoic sadness
can't you hire someone cost a hundred
bucks a night to hire someone to make
sure she doesn't fall
no she needs to think before she opens
her mouth don't you think it should cost
less to be alive
absolutely
[Music]
there's this comic book i was obsessed
with as a kid it's about this species of
half alien half demon creatures in the
scary stories that they tell each other
oh god
are all about us
humans
i know you think there's something wrong
with me it's not a
news you'll find someone new you're
going to come out of this stronger
stop lying to me just
stop
don't actually stop
the only thing i say makes her yeah or
she reminds you you me you it's you my
friend
i love that in times like this i have a
home base a family i can always come
home to
to knowing this is what matters right
here
[Applause]
because everything anyone's got
the better we are
everything you have goes
[Music]
well that's the positive way of looking
at things
wow do that at a funeral day
[Music]
[Music]
you